Hello, I'm Gav.
And I'm Dan.
And we're the slo-mo guys.
I'm gone for two seconds.
What has happened here? What has happened?
Hello, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We are the slo-mo guys.
Yeah.
Here today with Rhett and Link.
I've realized I'm just waving this saber.
Give me that, any bladed
things, give them to me.
Okay.
Thanks a bunch for
coming to my back garden.
Yeah thanks for having us.
And being on slo-mo guys.
It is an honor to be here.
We once nicked one of
your ideas for a video.
We did the corn drill.
Oh, yeah.
That we saw on your show
and we did it on slo-mo
and made a mess of Dan's face.
Whoa!
How was it? You like corn?
I do like corn, but we put ketchup on it
and I don't like corn and ketchup.
I've never heard of that.
No one's ever heard of corn and ketchup.
Was it just, it was for the visual effect.
It was for the visual effect
For the spray.
Because butter wouldn't do the same thing.
No.
No, but what it did, it sort
of formed this corn paste
that went all up into
the roof of his mouth
and he was just like.
Oh, it wasn't nice.
Looked good though, so you know whatever.
Right.
So what we thought we
would try and do today is
saber a champagne bottle open.
Which is a thing.
Well this is an actual,
this is specifically a champagne saber.
I didn't know there, I thought
you just used knives and that
but it's actually quite-
It's actually completely,
it's not sharp at all.
Oh you know what?
Oh that's good.
That means that Link
can actually touch it.
He's not allowed to touch-
Oh you're allowed to touch?
He's not allowed to touch sharp things.
Okay.
Link, you can see what
it's like to hold a knife.
Yeah, look at that.
It's almost a knife.
All right, I'm starting to
get worried there, come on.
That might have been
a little out of focus,
but I had to do that for emphasis.
What is the occasion they do it?
It has to be really swanky, right?
No, I think the occasion
is when you don't have a
a corkscrew.
So you mean I could take
that home and be like
where's the cork-
nevermind, just grab that.
You don't use a corkscrew
on champagne though.
Yeah you do use a corkscrew.
No yeah, you don't need anything.
All you do is unscrew.
That's true.
Just thumb it away.
Oh you thumb it away.
You shake it and thumb it.
This is entirely unnecessary.
So it's when you don't have a-
It's for show.
It's when you don't have a thumb.
I think it's if you I
don't have thumbs or if
you're sort of on a ship and
there's a wedding or something.
Yeah.
Or maybe some sort of-
Well is part of the process
actually breaking the bottle,
or are you just supposed to just
clip the cork?
You're supposed to clip
the top of the rim where the cork goes in
and it pops off the end.
Can you just hold thi-
actually you hold this.
Thank you.
It's blunt, I can hold it.
So these bottles have
been chilling in some ice
neck down for about 10 minutes
because it works much better
when the glass is cold.
And you see basically this ridge here
where the bottle's been molded.
Ah.
You see that?
Yeah.
It's a seam.
Yeah, it's like a seam.
If you pass me the saber,
what you want to do is line it up
sort of about here on the ogive
of the bottle
Is that a what?
Ogive?
It's a word.
I don't think it's used
for bottles, but anyway.
And then you want to slide it along
and keep swinging through
and you're going to aim to
hit that little ridge there
with the saber.
But we'll see how good you are.
Maybe we'll do a little
competition between us,
see who's best at it.
Oh.
Yeah.
Challenge accepted.
I'm ready.
Who's up first?
Dan, I feel like you should go because
you seem-
You seem to know.
Yeah, you read some instructions.
Okay, all right. I'll go first.
It's a bit of a grim day,
so we have the light on
shooting this 1,000 frames a second in 4K.
Here we go.
I'm wearing gloves in case I don't-
Oh!
Popped!
That was actually really good!
It was perfect.
And now you shove that into your mouth.
Is that what you do with it?
That's not bad actually.
All right, it's a wrap.
See you later.
It's not going to get
any better than that.
I mean I've seen it
cleaner than that before.
Yeah it's kind of-
It's kind of a bit jagged.
Don't put your hand so close.
Yeah that is sharp now, okay.
No touching that.
Why do you got to get so close to things?
I was just doing that.
No, come on.
It's just like why do you
it's so weird your compulsion
to want to hurt yourself.
No, I don't want to hurt myself,
I just want to gesture over sharp things.
Right, so yeah, I've seen it done before
where it's been completely flat
where the rim is just
basically cut off nicely.
Yeah, I'm going to do that.
Yeah?
I think we should be like,
well I've done it, so I
get at least five out of 10
and then the jaggedness
of it, you lose marks for.
Yep.
So.
So you're coming up with a scoring system?
Yeah, I reckon like a
6.7.
I'm going to give that a 6.
Okay yeah, definitely
higher than five, 6.7?
Yeah.
So we're rating ourselves?
That's safe.
Fine, you rate me. How
did I do? How did I do?
I'd say about a 6.6.
6.6 from Rhett, how do
you feel about that?
Okay, yeah, I'm fine with it, first try.
So you maintained contact with
the bottle the whole time?
Well look at the face.
Yeah you have to maintain
contact with the bottle.
Oh that was lovely.
Look it came off just
one nice clean chunk.
Lovely.
I closed my eyes, look.
Your face.
That's my concentration face.
Look something went,
something went backwards.
Did it?
Glass went backwards.
Wait the glass went-
No.
Over your left shoulder.
Most of the glass
went back towards you, look.
So safety goggles?
Yes, safety goggles.
I think.
Oh my gosh, did you see that?
It went right over your shoulder.
I think safety goggles
and maybe two gloves?
Yeah.
I mean it's out of focus there now.
Judging by the focus, that
must have been not far.
Yeah I got to find that.
It's not a total blur.
Look at my confused face.
Look at you looking at the end
of it, like you didn't know
it was going to look like that.
My theory is that the glass
coming back towards you
was an anomaly that just
happened on the first one.
I think so.
I think we should wear safety goggles.
Yeah.
If you have them, but
I don't think it's going to happen again
because people would be
Constantly worried about it.
Yeah, I mean it would just
be happening all the time.
Ready?
Yes.
Three two.
Oh, that was quite a sound.
That one was-
Whoa, look at that. Whoa!
I'm annoyed.
Definitely more points for
the cleanliness of that.
Oh it's very clean.
But also the sound deserves more points.
And I made contact with the fence.
Yeah.
Did I not?
Mine was dropped, just drooped.
Yeah it was just like bleh.
Oh no, that is embarrassing.
All right, I'm awaiting your rating
which hopefully
is higher than 6.6.
I would actually give you
to be honest, the only
thing I would say is that
if you want it perfectly it would be
around the out
On the whole thing.
The whole thing, but I'd give you
an 8.3.
Woo!
Yeah absolutely.
I might get a part-time
job at a steak restaurant.
Yeah 8.4 I think.
Here you go, is this your one?
Oh, it kept the cork.
It kept the cork
and everything.
Oh, it's part of it.
I can't even, I think that is actually it,
one piece.
That's why it hit the
fence because it stayed,
the cork stayed with it.
You totally went on two, didn't you?
Yeah you did.
You did one, two.
Here we go.
Pop.
One piece!
Ah like butter.
Even the jet was one, yours was like-
Mine came out, I had a split,
what do they call it when that happens?
When it comes in two streams.
So proud as well.
Yeah, the pride face.
Look at that drip.
That's a solid drip.
Not that much champagne burst out.
That's, you get more
points for that as well
because you-
Right, you don't want to waste champagne.
Yeah minimal wastage.
Because when I get the job
at the fancy restaurant
it's going to be very expensive champagne.
Yeah, I don't think you can
wear gloves and eye mask
in the fancy restaurant.
Again, so far my theory is holding up
that I think that the glass
coming back towards you
is just an anomaly that
happened on the first time.
Well this would be in with that theory.
Yeah, nothing came back.
So how are you feeling?
How am I feeling?
I feel very nervous because I was hoping
at this point someone would
have really messed it up
but we've had two pretty good hits.
I thank you.
Okay.
Red circle?
Yep.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Oh yeah!
That was horizontal.
Oh God!
That's a 10!
Did any champagne come out?
No, you lost
no champagne.
None at all.
Hold up, I got to find the thing.
That is supreme.
I don't even think the edges are sharp.
Oh look at that, look
at that, look at that.
You did it!
It came off.
What!
You want to bring in the camera?
Yeah, can you hold this for me?
I'll just do a little bit of-
Guys I can't tell you how relieved I am.
Look at your work!
I'm not sure if I'm like happy.
Have you been reading
Wikipedia or something?
No, I've- I don't even know how to read.
I know I said 10
initially.
You said 10, I heard you.
We got it on camera.
I believe that there is
a possibility that it
could be better because
it's not
completely.
Right there.
So I'm going to say 9.9.
Okay.
If you look at, it's not just straight.
If we had a spirit level.
Dan, your theory was that
the bottles are getting colder and colder.
Yeah, they're getting colder.
So the glass is getting more brittle
so Link, that sets you
up for the opportunity
to take home the win or the 10, right?
Oh.
Yeah.
Well let's watch this back first.
I look really annoyed, I wasn't.
Here we go.
Eyes are definitely closed.
What?
Just a little.
So clean!
No champagne, no champagne.
Not even a drop.
How did that even happen?
No, you didn't lose any.
None at all.
I lost a bit of vapor, but
I think we'll let that-
That's unbelievable.
It's amazing how the puff overtakes
it goes further than the cork.
That's going to be very difficult to beat.
Almost unbeatable.
Because I haven't been able
to hold anything like this
for such a long time-
Out of practice right?
I'm really, really out of practice here.
Here you go, Link.
I'm nervous watching you with that thing.
Look at that, I feel like a swashbuckler.
Look at that, I mean if I do this,
if I win,
then I get to use knives
on Good Mythical Morning.
Is that fair?
Again.
If you beat a 10? If you
beat a 9.9 and get a 10?
If I match it, yeah.
Okay, if you get a 10, I'll
let you use sharp things
on Good Mythical Morning.
I think that's a deal.
I'm not going to give
him a 10, don't worry.
Here we go.
All right, hold on, I've got to save that.
I didn't want to push too
hard, because it said be
gentle.
He's never using
knives again.
I don't know if that counts.
That doesn't count.
Was that like a practice
swing in golf or something?
Where like he misses the ball, he's like
now I'm ready.
You know because of this
camera and the framery,
I took like 4,000 pictures of that.
Of nothing.
Of nothing happening.
So you messed up for a long time.
I'm going ham.
All right.
Three two.
What have you done to this bottle?
Is this-
Third time's a charm.
I'm stepping further back for some reason.
Now I'm thinking about
my own children watching,
they're disappointed in Dad.
Dangit.
I mean I could just cut out
the failed attempts, right?
Oh okay, yeah.
Why are you shaking your head no?
I can cut out the failed attempts.
This is my first attempt.
Gavin?
Yes, that's correct.
This is my first attempt.
Are you nervous?
Oh, this is your first try.
Look at the determination in the face,
it's getting more each time.
What do you mean each time?
I mean the first-
His face.
I feel like we couldn't plan this.
Okay.
This is for real.
Three, two.
Yeah, I did it!
I did it!
Put the knife down!
Look at that!
Very good!
On my first attempt, I have completely-
That is very.
That's pretty good right?
Well, here's the thing.
There's a little-
You've lost a
fair amount of
You've lost more champagne.
The top is, I would say it is equivalent.
I think it was better
than our two, actually.
Definitely.
But not as good as Gav's.
So, I mean you've got to score it.
Well, okay so that was your what,
your third attempt?
I don't recall.
I think I lost count.
Yeah, I did it!
Forget about the other attempts.
For that attempt alone, I'd give you 9.4.
Is there any sort of
handicap because it is Link?
Right, I haven't touched any
saber-like device in years.
Well technically, we need
to remove two whole points.
So the maximum ceiling would be eight
because it's your third attempt, right?
Oh okay.
But because you haven't
touched knives in so long,
you get an extra two point ceiling.
So we're back to nine.
You're back to 9.4.
I'd say that's fair.
So that means that Gavin you had the-
Gavin had overall the best,
but I think that if you do all the math,
I think team Rhett and Link
might have walked out
of here with a victory.
Oh yeah.
So yeah, are we adding
those scores together?
We are.
Yeah I think you won actually.
Gotta do it.
Because mine was definitely the worst one.
But it was the first, it
was the least cold bottle.
It's true.
Well done, guys.
Thank you, Gavin.
Thanks for coming here and
wiping the floor with us.
Can I watch my attempt back?
You can, yes.
You know what, actually, I deleted it.
It didn't go.
Oh, you have to do it again.
So here we have a little bit of Dan.
Pretty pathetic.
That's Rhett.
That's mine.
We look like twins.
Yeah we do, yeah we do.
That little bit right
there is a compromise, but-
You can put it right back on the bottle
and no one would ever know it was
it was broken.
I was mostly concentrating
on the face I was making
for my first attempt.
I think that was-
Oh, that's the excuse
you're going for, I like it.
No, I really was focusing.
I was like I want to look chill about it.
You want to look badass about it.
My face didn't even change.
Yeah, your face didn't change.
Oh, we're having a good time back there.
Look at the shame.
I've never seen slow-motion shame before.
We captured a raw emotion.
That's amazing!
That is shame and
embarrassment right there.
In the dictionary, it
should be next to dammit.
Okay.
Thank you, thank you
guys for capturing that.
You concentrate much more then.
You can see the extra determination.
And, oof.
Oh yeah.
Look at that.
There's a lot of champagne.
Very cool though.
Quite a lot of champagne,
but it made it look good.
And you got all this
coming towards cameras
so it's going all soft, love it.
That is pretty nice
Look at that.
Actually, it looks really nice.
Your one didn't have any
champagne, but it was kind of like-
I think actually at a party
you would want to do that.
Yeah mine has what I'd like to-
That would get people cheering.
I like to call that the
constellation effect.
You really pushed hard down.
You can see the angle on your sword
as it's about to hit the cap.
If you pause it right when
it's about to hit the cap,
he is almost in a 90 degree angle.
And then look where the sword went for us,
the sword went outwards right?
Yeah, mine went down.
For you, it went completely down.
You were really putting
the pressure on it.
Yeah you cut through your flow.
How do you feel that your
celebration face was?
Think it's a good one?
Because we're about to see it.
Yeah.
It kind of just got angrier.
That's it right there.
Champion.
Vindication.
Now, I've seen a lot of videos online,
a lot of fail videos
where they just straight up explode.
And I was honestly hoping that
one of us would do that today.
So maybe we can sort of
skew the results in
our favor a little bit.
What and just do it wrong?
Do it deliberately wrong.
Okay.
Well seeing as I did the worst,
should I try and do that?
Yeah.
If I pull this off, do I win?
It's up for debate.
You do something remarkably awesome
then I think we'll give
you guys the victory.
All right, I'm up for that.
Frame up, tell me when you're ready.
Ready.
Oh I did the cork!
Oh my God!
Look at that!
He did just the cork!
Oh my God!
That, what!
First of all-
That's a parlor trick.
First of all, you get the victory.
Oh my gosh.
That's like-
Wow.
That's unbelievable.
What!
Technically, that's the
way that you should do it.
Is that what you were trying to do?
Yes, yes, that's what I was trying to do.
Yeah I had that big wind up.
That was amazing!
Yeah you just gave me
the saber and ran away.
I take a real wind up here
because I'm trying to smash the glass.
You just go for it.
And look at the angle, I mean-
I took an absolute golf
swing at it as well.
Look at that left hand, so steady.
Fore!
Oh you move it back just a teeny bit.
That is straight cork, look at that.
No way!
Could you do that again?
I don't think so.
I actually don't think
I could ever do that again.
Let's see
where on the cork that hit.
I mean it caught, I mean-
Look at it.
Solid, it didn't just skim it.
I mean it was a solid cork hit.
Like a-
I just-
Like a micrometer north or south
and that wouldn't have happened.
That was nothing but net.
Nothing, that was swift.
I mean that's it, man, that's what
everybody wants.
I was confused.
Look at my- I was like what?
And then Rhett's running
towards like, Oh my God!
I'm Chariots of Fire to get up there.
Look at that sprint!
There's so much emotion in this video.
I mean, it just-
We just witnessed history.
You know what this calls for, celebration!
Yeah, we got one more left.
You want to just do a
better job of trashing it?
I'll try and trash it this time.
Ready?
That went all kinds of backwards.
Goodness me.
I mean even still, much
cleaner break than I've seen.
I would still drink out of that.
Look at that.
Look at this piece coming towards Gavin.
Oh is that the piece that hit you?
That was what hit my ankle, yeah. Conk.
That's this piece right here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is how not to saber.
But I do think we have to
recalibrate the score because
with the magic that you pulled
Well how can
With just hitting the cork.
The clean corkage.
How can we have a 9.9 and then
me only get 0.1 better than
that with the cork right?
I mean I think we've
got to adjust the scale.
Do I get an 11?
I'd give you an 11 man, that
was amazing.
Maybe it's just a tie.
A tie?
Maybe it's just a draw.
Okay.
You know what, that yeah.
And then we'll all be happy.
we'll walk away feeling very medium
about the whole experience.
We can still be friends.
I feel all right about this.
Okay, let's call it a draw, call it a day.
Well guys, I think we've all done some
bloody good work then.
Yeah we did.
Cheers all around.
Oh, careful.
Thanks so much for having us.
Thanks for coming and
being on our channel.
We've done a video with you, haven't we?
Yeah.
Slo-mo burgers.
And thank you very much
for watching this video.
Hopefully you enjoyed it.
It was an absolute roller
coaster of emotions.
Don't try this at home,
do you have to say that?
I don't think we have to,
but we probably should.
Yeah don't try at home.
Don't try at home.
What if I said, try this at home.
Yeah, well I think it's three
out of four said don't, so.
Yeah, it's outnumbered, yeah.
You'll be the one who gets sued.
We got a lovely we got a lovely tie
at the end of that.
No winners no losers.
Subscribe to us, subscribe to these guys.
The buttons are all on the screen.
That's right, you can do it.
You can do both.
Pour one out for the homies.
That's a waste.
Yeah let's not, that's a good point.
Yeah, going to kill those weeds.
Oh don't .